[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covin 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi anciens ministres et
directeurs généraux de la santé
elle s'était vous propose de revivre
tout l'été ces auditions aujourd'hui
celle de jean françois delfraissy
c'est le président du conseil
scientifique créée en réaction à cette
épidémie de covin 19
les scientifiques ont-ils confisquer le
pouvoir aux politiques
le confinement était-il nécessaire
craint-il une deuxième vague
voici les questions au coeur de son
audition mais ce professeur la mission
vous avez entendus à la mi avril une
date à laquelle ont commencé à réfléchir
aux conditions d'un futur déconfinement
deux mois plus tard nous avons jugé
important de tirer avec vous un premier
bilan de la crise sanitaire
quel regard portez-vous sur le déroulé
des événements et des décisions qui ont
été prises
les conclusions qu'il faudrait en tirer
au terme en termes de moyens
d'organisation sanitaire de mobilisation
de la recherche et enfin comment peut-on
anticiper les prochains mois apprécier
les risques d'un retour redouter de
l'épidémie avant d'aborder ces questions
et de vous donner la parole je vais vous
demander à tous les quatre de prêter
serment
je vous invite donc à lever la main
droite est à dire je le jure je vous en
remercie
je rappelle que cette audition et public
elle est diffusée en direct consultable
en vidéo et fera l'objet d'un compte
rendu écrit sur le président vous avez
la parole pour un propos liminaire
je vous ai demandé cours qui précédera
notre échange sous forme surtout de
questions réponses
merci
jon hamm je suis sûr qu'il y aura des
questions sur les masques
je me présente sur un sol frais si je
suis professeur d'immunologie j'ai passé
la plus grande partie de ma carrière a
dirigé à être dans la lutte contre le
vih sida dirigé l'agencé nationale de
recherches sur le sida puis l'institut
de maladies infectieuses j'avais été
nommée déléguée interministérielle de la
lutte contre ebola et dans la
construction des de la réponse aux
crises
j'avais été à l'origine de la
construction de réacteurs ces structures
qui est une structure de recherche qui
pour répondre aux crises sanitaires
j'ai souhaité venir avec trois membres
du conseil scientifique pour bien
indiquer que ce conseil scientifique
n'était pas c'était pas le conseil
scientifique du président du conseil
scientifique mais que c'était une oeuvre
commune multidisciplinaire j'y
reviendrai avec je dirais une
construction humble parce que sur des
sujets difficiles et qui reste avec
plein d'impôts dus au service du citoyen
et avec une certaine forme finalement
d'un d'essayer d'en tout cas d'avoir eu
une intelligence collective qui se
construit à plusieurs et non pas à tout
seul alors je voudrais discuter avec
vous en préliminaire de 5 points qui
sont les suivants le premier qui sommes
nous
le deuxième comment nous avons
fonctionné le troisième nos relations
avec les agences les institutions de
collègues étrangers
le quatrième les relations avec le
politique et le cinquième
ce que nous ne sommes pas et n'avons pas
été sur le premier point qui sommes-nous
donc que vous avez rappelé le nôtre
création avec sous la forme d'un objet
non identifié le 11 mars
j'ai dit non d'identité parce que ne
reposant pas sur sur quelque chose de
sûre un décret mais seulement sur une
une nomination est elle a été confirmée
ensuite dans le cadre de la lotte friis
d'urgence comme on en était arrivé là
moi même je reconnais volontiers que je
n'ai
et conscience de la gravité de la crise
que relativement tardivement que aux
alentours du 20 février à la fois d'un
retour d'une grande réunion qui avait
lieu à l'om s où j'étais d'ailleurs non
pas sur la crise sanitaire
mais sur la vision éthique de cette
crise sanitaire
j'avais été frappé surtout par le fait
que les chinois ne disait rien et que
donc s'il ne disait rien c'est qu'ils
nous mais ce qui est un certain nombre
de choses
il y avait par ailleurs les données
italiennes il y avait des données de nos
colères et animateur qui commençaient à
s'accumuler et puis les premiers
contacts avec les modélisateurs à partir
de là j'avais donné un signal d' alerte
à l'elysée la nouvelle conseillère santé
à l'époque qui venait d'arriver
et ça aboutit à la création et d'une
d'une réunion de 23 scientifiques dont
un certain nombre d'entre nous le 5 mars
et puis à la constitution du comité
scientifique ensuite ce comité il est
multidisciplinaire c'est ce qui fait la
richesse du gros on est à la fois il ya
la fois de des virologues des
spécialistes des maladies infectieuses
dans les animatrices qui est avec nous
aujourd'hui
des modélisateurs des gens de santé
publique mais aussi des jamais souhaité
qu'ils aient des membres de sciences
humaines et sociales parce qu'on s'est
tous une crise sanitaire
elle est salutaire au début qu'elle
devient rapidement politique et qu'elle
finit toujours en sociétale et j'avais
souhaité aussi et c'est elle est arrivée
seconde errements qui est un
représentant de la société civile et
donc une représentante qui est la vice
présidente de la société de
l'association addes été clairement qui a
choisi les membres
ça se met très vite un sas effet le 10
et le 11 d'une discussion entre le
ministre de la santé
la conseillère santé à l'elysée et moi
même on a donné un certain nombre de
noms on a regardé il il ya des personnes
que je ne connaissais pas le jeu ne
connaissez pas l'ida et c'était vraiment
une superbe découverte
je ne connaissais pas non plus d'autres
membres et inversement je connaissais
d'autres mans sur lequel m'appuyer bien
sûr bruno bien sûr et arnaud fontaine
est également donc c'est un mélange dans
la entre les propositions que j'ai pu
faire et ça du ministre de la santé et
de la conseillère santé de l'elysée
donc c'est un ce comité très
multidisciplinaire et disons le un
comité d'experts auprès du gouvernement
qui est là pour éclairer les décisions
gouvernementales et je ne leur dirai
jamais assez c'est le gouvernement qui
décide et ce qu'on a pu lire à une
certaine époque dans les journaux qui
avaient un troisième pouvoir sanitaire
en france
voilà c'est une vaste blague comme on a
eu de vaste blague des médias pendant
les trois mois qui viennent et c'est
bien sûr ce sont des décisions qui sont
décision gouvernementale
comment avons-nous travailler c'est plus
de 100 réunions trois mois les tout par
téléphone on a rapidement quitté l'audio
parce que on se retrouvait finalement
avec une utilisation
deux vidéos ou d'autres des amis à nous
retrouver entendez ce qu'on disait donc
on est revenu à des conférences audio
une par jour souvent une de soi le
week-end ça aboutit à des décisions qui
sont des décisions collégiales
collégiale parce que on part d'une idée
chacun a son idée avec ed une fois de
plus des spécialités différentes et on
construit quelque chose de commun alors
c'est pas nouveau c'est pas le causse et
le comité scientifique covit français
d'abord ya de nombreux comités
scientifiques du même modèle qui se sont
fait à l'europe et par ailleurs ce
mécanisme de construction commune est
quelque chose qui existe en médecine jeu
c'est souvent quand on parle des
mandarins et de la décision top down
mais finalement ça a beaucoup changé au
cours des 15 dernières années et la
majorité finalement des décisions
médecine se prend à partir d'une
décision qui est commune est une
construction commune on voit si on a
souhaité avoir des avis et des écrits on
a souhaité la transparence vous l'avez
rappelé madame la présidente et aider
nos avis ont été toujours donné avec un
certain décalage parfois un peu trop
long parfois mais ils ont été toujours
donner donner au public
donc ce mode de travail est un travail
qui est un mode de travail qui peut
paraître original mais il ne l'est pas
en fait c'est le mode de travail de la
médecine moderne d'une construction qui
n'est pas et de la science moderne d'une
construction pour prendre des décisions
qui se construit à plusieurs et qui
s'appuie sur l'interdisciplinarité
donc il ya une dynamique de groupe qui
s'est créé je dois dire que je les
remercie je remercierai à la fin mais on
a eu un comité scientifique de haut
niveau ils sont tous de revivre une grue
scientifique médicale et qui a
pleinement le jouer le jeu alors qu'il
avait plein d'autres choses à faire
soit dans le dans le soin et dans le
soin difficile que l'on a connues soit
dans la recherche avec des choses pointu
qui devait sortir on à nous-mêmes
construit un règlement intérieur qui a
été a été mis en place dès la fin mars
début avril et l'ensemble des membres
bien sûr déposé des dpi
et au cas où il y avait un certain
nombre de membres avaient des liens
d'intérêts et au cas où ses liens
d'intérêt aurait pu avoir une importance
sur des pas des décisions une fois de
plus mais sur des éclairages que nous
pouvions apporter est bien un des ports
étaient prévus mais vous verrez tout à
l'heure qu'on n'a pas pris partie sur
les aspects thérapeutiques deux grands
moments
je dirais dans l'avis du comité les amis
1 2 3 4 qui étaient autour du
confinement ses conséquences et on a été
vraiment dans un dans quelque chose qui
lui nous à nous même sidéré 1 comment
ned finalement des décisions
gouvernementales à prendre une décision
aussi difficile que le confinement
généralisée je les dis je vous le répète
devant vous je n'ai pas dormi pendant
trois quatre nuits 1 à la suite de ça
c'est à dire c'est aucune certitude il
quelque chose de très difficile pour
aider à prendre cette décision en notre
âme et conscience
quelque chose qui ne s'était jamais
produit donc ça c'est un première série
d'avis une série de 2e série d'amis qui
est beaucoup plus et vous l'avez rappelé
de type de décision stratégique de
vision stratégique où nous allons c'est
à dire une fois la phase de dettes
d'avoir aidé à cette décision
le confinement était là comment
s'organiser comment s'organise mieux
pour sortir du confinement pour avoir
une période post confinement et pour
éviter de retomber dans le confinement
qui serait totalement une décision qui
serait une porte de sortie que commande
que nous n'envisageons pas et donc cette
vision stratégique elle est au tour
finalement d'une réflexion de santé
publique
alors c'est c'est la vie si ce qui est
sûr le déconfinement quels outils
quelles pré requis et aboutissant
finalement une proposition de notre part
de date pour début mai le président de
la république ensuite tranché autour du
11 mai et celle avis est qu'il est le
dernier après de déconfinement qu'est ce
qui va se passer dans les semaines qui
vont venir quelques quel scénario avec
les quatre scénarios que nous
envisageons et quels plans de
préparation et de prévention est à
mettre en place dans justement cette
période un peu plus calme dans laquelle
nous sommes entrés
autour de cela on a chaque fois insisté
sur l'aspect de gouvernance qui est le
pilote dans l'avion durant toute cette
période
c'est pas seulement le fait de décider
mais c'est ensuite de rendre au niveau
opérationnel par l'ensemble des services
de l'état les grandes des options qui
ont pu être prises et j'insiste sur ce
point parce que ça reste une question
d'actualité et je dois dire que sur les
aspects opérationnels qui n'était pas
notre problème
on a vu a vu arriver avec un bonheur son
nom la mission castex pendant un mois où
nous avions en face de nous du répondant
entre guillemets on posait des questions
ont soulevé une série de problèmes et on
avait des éléments de construction de
réponse est un des éléments essentiels
durant l'été va être que dans le poste
mission castex
cette convergence à la fois entre le
central et le régional le central et les
territoires puissent se faire avec plus
de fluidité qu'elle ne sait pas jusqu'à
maintenant le troisième point c'est la
relation avec les autres commutation les
agences et et puis les différentes
structures académiques qui peut y avoir
en effet pourquoi cet objet nouveau du
comité scientifique
alors que la france a une série d'
agences sanitaires
pourquoi au nom de quoi est-ce que c'est
pas nous qui avons demandé à être dans
un conseil dans un comité scientifique
on nous a nommé mais on s'est quand même
posé la question de ne pas apparaître
comme un élément de surcouche à la
française ça et qu'on adore ça et donc
dès le début en tout cas on a souhaité
et bien avoir de l'interaction avec
santé publique france on a proposé la
santé publique france d'être un
observateur permanent et ils ont à peu
près ils ont ils sont à peu près venu à
beaucoup de nos réunions
le haut comité de santé publique et j'ai
demandé personnellement à son président
de faire partie il a été nommé comme
membre du comité scientifique
et puis bien sûr la recherche avec
liaison liaison pana qui pilotait
reacting donc l'enjeu n'est général de
la part de nous tous au sein du comité
n'était pas de dire on est le comité sur
wat circulez y'a rien à
c'était pas ça du tout l'objet l'objet
était de dire qu'est ce qu'on pouvait
apporter de plus par rapport à ce que
n'apportait pas ou en tout cas apporté
insuffisamment finalement le les agences
deuxième élément on a essayé d'avoir des
relations avec les académies médecine
sciences avec eux les l'ensemble des
réseaux de sociétés savantes on a passé
beaucoup de temps à leur expliquer qui
on est et qui on faisait un peu ce que
je suis en train de leur poser des
questions à leur demande et sur des
éléments de science supplémentaires par
exemple le virus et l'environnement avec
le cnrs le virus et le climat où on a
fait venir
on avait des dialogues avec un certain
nombre de grands scientifiques qu'on
invitait à nos anneaux à nos réunions
téléphoniques et puis une série de
relations avec eux des homologues
étrangers puisque avec des modèles
différents selon les pays en fonction de
la culture de leur histoire est de plus
ou moins grande capacité à faire du
fédéralisme du centralisme à la
française est bien globalement partout
il ya eu l'équivalent de comités
scientifiques notre relation avec le
politique c'est une crise sans précédent
moi j'ai vécu déjà des crises très
difficile on l'oubli 1
mais le vih sida quand j'avais 35 ans ou
40 ans - a été une crise très difficile
également ebola été une crise très
difficile mais vous en êtes très peu
aperçu en métropole et en france mais ça
a été une triste très difficile en
guinée donc j'ai vécu déjà des crises
difficiles
très honnêtement un impact aussi brutale
que cette crise je ne l'avais jamais
passé par sa rapidité tout s'accélère et
on a l'impression qu'on crise sanitaire
ça s'accélère aussi dans une certaine
façon alors ce que beat et par rapport
au politique
on a été nommé par les politiques et
inversement
on a tous passé notre temps à dire que
la décision était du politique et qu'on
est et cela seulement pour l'éclairer et
on essayait de garder une autonomie et
une indépendance avec un équilibre
évidemment qui est difficile à trouver
mais que je pense qui a été en partie
trouvé c'est un éclairage d'experts
indépendant sans notion de hiérarchie on
appartient tous à des structures
diverses
on n'avait pas rendre compte si vous
voulez comme un directeur d'agencé
sanitaire ou comme un directeur de
grandes administrations
on était indépendant et vous savez que
en plus dans le modèle français le
milieu médical est un milieu très
indépendant parfois trop d'ailleurs en
tant que prêtre au nez et y donc il ya
une indépendance de pensée et de liberté
de ton qui n'est pas celle évidemment
dagan directeur d' agences parce que
nous n'étions rien finalement
nous n'étions qu'un groupe d'experts qui
se réunissait tous les jours donc une
parole libre alors c'est des mondes
différents
1 entre science et politique c'est
comment fait-on comprendre politique que
le doute et l'incertitude font partie
intégrante de la science et qu'on avance
en sciences que si on a des doutes et de
l'incertitude
j'arrête compatibles quand on vous dit
mais j'ai besoin de savoir évidemment
pour décider pour prendre des décisions
et pourtant le doute et l'incertitude
sont un élément essentiel s'il n'y a
plus de doutes et incertitudes
il n'y a plus de science que le temps de
la science n'est pas le temps médiatique
surtout avec eux les médias actuels et
le barnum médiatique que nous avons pu
avoir pendant trois mois que le temps de
la science n'est pas le temps du
politique non plus la science prend du
temps on construit pas des essais
thérapeutiques contrôlé sur une période
de 15 jours
on ne construit pas une vision de ce
qu'est la réaction immunitaire très
particulière de ce virus en donnant des
résultats cage et le politique pourtant
des résultats à très court terme donc
c'est intéressant mais c'est pas l'objet
aujourd'hui mais dans la construction
même de la relation entre science et
politique
et de s'interroger si en france cette
question l'a été a été réellement mise à
plat au cours des 20 dernières années
je n'en suis pas certain je n'en suis
pas certain et c'est une vraie question
peut-être non pas pour ce une fois de
plus substituer il ya la science elle
est plus large sur les crises sanitaires
mais dans l'art c'est la relation qui
peut y avoir des chances fructueux
à voir il ya probablement le modèle du
conseil scientifique
en tout cas mérite d'être poursuivi
d'une certaine façon d'être réfléchi
alors il n'y a pas de troisième pouvoir
médical je les ai déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises globalement cette relation
délicate avec le politique c'est fait je
pense que les membres du conseil
scientifique sont d'accord avec moi dans
un climat de confiance
on essaie en permanence de me faire dire
que ça s'est mal passé avec le pouvoir
politique
la réponse est non il ya eu un climat de
confiance qui s'est installée avec d'une
part les conseillers de matignon
l'elysée est vrai qu'il y avait des
liens du journal y est plus riche
journalier on leur a donné des signaux
avec des notes informel des choses qui
des coups de fil aux traditions vous
pouvez comprendre dans une situation de
crise pareille
une réunion au plus haut niveau avec le
père lpn tous les quinze jours encore
plus plus proche dans l'étroit dans les
trois ou quatre premières réunions mais
qui ensuite s'est poursuivie avec pas
toujours tous les membres du comité
scientifique
certains au début par eux par vidéo
ensuite de nouveau on fait tout face à
l'elysée avec des notes et des avis
publics où nous avions tous souhaité
avoir une transparence vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens car finalement le rôle du
conseil scientifique
c'est aussi c'est bien sûr des
d'éclairer le politique mais c'est aussi
d'éclairer dans une certaine mesure le
citoyen notre objectif on a on n'avait
rien à y gagner on n'a qu'à y perde on
passe devant vous là et on va être avoir
probablement toute une série de
questions mais notre rôle et c'est
normal mais notre rôle
c'était finalement d'ap d'apporter
quelque chose je suis médecin mais
j'avais une consultation encore le leu
leu leu leu juste le 11 mars
c'est pas parce qu'on me voit pas en
mousse blanche que je suis pas médecin
donc notre rôle est d'apporter ce que
nous pouvions faire de mieux pour le
citoyen alors ddd des propositions ont
été globalement plutôt accepté il ya eu
des positions divergentes sur les écoles
par exemple sur une proposition du
comité scientifique sur le comité de
liaison citoyenne moi je je pensais que
il semblait qu'on avait pris une série
de décisions très top down au début et
c'était assez logique de la part du
politique mais que ensuite sur aborder
les problèmes de suivi de confinement de
déconfinement de postes confinement un
dialogue avec la société civile aurait
été intéressant avec la nomination d'un
qu'habiter citoyens le politique ne nous
a pas suivis là dessus je leur ai dit
qu'ils avaient tort et que je le
regrettais et je pense qu'ils ont eu
tort parce que un dialogue sur ce que
pensent et la société la construction au
moment du des confirmands aurait
probablement à apporter apporter quelque
chose
néanmoins je sais pas si vous l'avez
remarqué mais il ya une petite musique
dans l'ensemble des avis qui est que dès
les avis du conseil scientifique se sont
on donnait finalement une responsabilité
à chacun des individus sur une série de
décisions
vous êtes responsable de la décision que
vous prenez vous êtes responsable de
mètres de remettre vos enfants l'école
ou pas vous êtes responsable si vous
avez plus de 70 ans de rester un peu
plus confiné ou pas du tout alors je
sais qu'on m'a fait dire que j'avais
souhaité que tous les que tous les
personnes de plus de soixante dix ans
soit confient des noms c'était une
recommandation oublions pas quand même
que 85 % des décès son déchet plus de 70
ans
on la sent la sueur un peu au début
beaucoup à la fin et ça reste vrai ça
reste une question pour la suite
le fait d'avoir stop que vides ou
pasteur qu'ovide avec soin le fait de
choisir le lieu d isolement quand on est
dépisté positif actuellement dépister
avec un diagnostic d'infection chez soi
ou dans une autre structure
et bien c'est de lui le fait de la
responsabilité citoyenne et je pense que
ce message la portée par le conseil
scientifique
nous l'avons mis comme une petite
musique et nous avons convaincu le
gouvernement de le porter également
alors dernier point je m'excuse je suis
un peu long et je termine là dessus
ce que nous ne sommes pas et ce que nous
n'avons pas été alors premièrement une
instance de décision qu est ce que j'ai
déjà raconté
nous sommes nous avons été une instance
éclairant le gouvernement c'est ce sont
des décisions politiques et
gouvernementales
nous ne sommes pas une instance pérenne
nous ne sommes pas une agence
on a un début et une fin on va
disparaître le 9 juillet on aurait même
souhaité disparaître avant et la loi ne
nous permet pas de le faire
on aurait souhaité disparaîtra non parce
que on pensait que la maintenant les
zinzins de l'ensemble des instances de
l'état je dirais et était en route était
en ordre de marche et que somme toute
notre rapport est et est maintenant plus
limitée sauf peut-être sur un point on
discutera la faction d'al temps sur
qu'est ce qu'on pense sur une deuxième
balle et peut-être c'est un des points
c'est une nous ne sommes pas et nous
n'avons pas été une instance
opérationnel aucune action directe sur
la commande des tests sur la mise en
oeuvre des recommandations
ça s'est appuyé sur le haut comité de
santé publique ça s'appuie sur les
divers grande direction sanitaire de
l'état mais nous n'avions pas en aucune
façon à pouvoir on était là pour
indiquer ce qu'il fallait faire mais pas
le pouvoir de passer les commandes ou
d'orienter vers tel ou tel type de
direction
par contre comme je les dis on a pris à
plusieurs toits des avis un avis très
clair sur une clarification de la
gouvernance quel est le pilote dans
l'avion entre le central et les
territoires la répartition de ce qui se
fait au niveau des ars qui pilote sur un
certain nombre de grandes directions et
avec donc sept mois très particulier je
dirais d'interaction avec le groupe k
sexe enfin dernier point nous n'avons
pas eu à nous occuper de recherche ni de
thérapeutique
alors je sais que ça peut paraître
lieu parce qu' un certain nombre d'entre
nous dont moi le premier sommes des
spécialistes du médicament vous savez
qu'il a été créé un deuxième comité le
comité caire dirigée par françoise barré
sinoussi que vous aurez probablement
l'occasion d'entendre qu'ils étaient là
pour à la fois faire un ciel une série
de recommandations sur des aspects de
recherche je dirais de beezik signed
proprement dit mais aussi d'essais
cliniques et l'essai thérapeutique est
somme toute nous nous sommes restés et
vous pouvez regarder l'ensemble de nos
avis nous n'avons pas pris parti nous
sommes restés dans une attitude de dire
voilà les outils que nous avons en face
de nous nous considérons et nous le
considérons toujours d'ailleurs qu'il
n'y a actuellement aucun médicament qui
a fait la preuve de son efficacité que
nous n'avons aucun vaccin disponible so
what
dans ces conditions quel type de
préconisations en termes de santé
publique nous pouvons faire donc voilà
enfin pour terminer je dirai que durant
toute cette période
il ya une évolution des connaissances et
c'est normal ce virus est un virus très
difficile et je parle sous le contrôle
d'un des spécialistes mondiaux avec
bruno mais c'est un virus j'ai dit c'est
un virus vache ou quelque chose comme ça
alors lors d'une intervention je
maintiens ma position même si elle est
pas tout à fait politiquement correct il
ya eu une évolution des connaissances
qui peut expliquer certaines difficultés
que nous avons eues voire même certains
changements que nous avons pu avoir
et après tout ne pas changer en sciences
ne pas changer on décisions peuvent pas
changer tous les jours mais ne pas tenir
compte de l'évolution des connaissances
est-ce aussi raisonnables on peut dire
s'il n'est pas raisonnable de changer
tout le temps mais il n'est pas
raisonnable de ne jamais changer en
tenant compte des connaissances comme
juste exemple je vous dirais sur la
transmission et la transmissibilité
l'histoire de progressive de la
construction des gouttelettes l'histoire
ddd des lieux particuliers où on peut ce
qu'on appelle les lieux 3c les lieux
confinés les lieux de foule les espaces
fermés les contacts étroits qui reste
totalement d'activit d'actualité il a
fallu le construire enfin vous savez que
les dernières
dernier point montre quelque chose
d'assez inattendu la notion de super
contaminateur et de super dissimulateur
qui ferait que peut-être l'ensemble des
visions qu'on a pu avoir sur quelqu'un
qui est infecté qui infecte ax personnes
elle est peut-être battu en brèche par
quelques super contaminateur ce serait
eux qu'il faudrait dans une certaine
mesure pouvoir dépister et l'histoire
n'est pas finie
l'immunité en population quelle fraction
de la population a fabriqué une immunité
de type anticorps par exemple bah on l
on est partis avec l'idée qu'on serait
peut-être à 30 40 % des travaux mais
dont beaucoup de travaux d'arnaud
d'ailleurs on montrait progressivement
avec des travaux internationaux qu'on
était à 10% 8 10%
on n'avait pas du tout ça début mars on
peut penser avec l'idée que cette
immunité de population serait plus
importante
l'acidification même des anticorps on
s'est posé à un moment donné si la
présence d'anticorps voulait dire qu'on
avait été en contact ou si on était en
partie protégé la question était
probablement plus clarifier maintenant
pourra y revenir si vous voulez enfin la
relation entre enfants et virus a changé
aussi par rapport à ce qu'on peut
laisser au début de l'épidémie et à la
fin donc j'ai terminé juste pour vous
dire que si on a du temps tout à l'heure
il faudra que peut-être il y en a une
question sur notre vision durant l'été
et notre vision sur sur la phase de
l'automne 1 on est assez clair et puis
je voudrais remercier d'une part les
gens profitent puisqu'on est à
l'assemblée nationale l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens qui a vécu une période
extrêmement difficile à jeu je me vois
encore la dante en ce2
le vraiment d'autour du 17-18 mars paris
s'éteindre j'étais juste avait dit de
mon balcon est à la fois moi j'ai
toujours fait confiance dans les
français pour les grandes décisions
ils ont été finalement vraiment très
bonne élève si je peux m'expliquer je
m'exprime est ainsi beaucoup mieux qu'on
ne veut bien le dire
beaucoup mieux et je et je les en
remercie parce que ils ont contribué à
faire un choix sanitaires et à protéger
dans une certaine mesure les plus
anciens et puis bien sûr vous
comprendrez que je remercie l'ensemble
des membres du comité scientifique qui a
fait un job d'enfer lors qu'ils avaient
je dirais en termes quantitatifs le
qualitatif je voulais seraient jugés
mais en termes quantitatifs plus de 100
réunions pas de week-end samedi dimanche
bo la production d'un certain nombre de
notes et puis aussi de notre jeune
stagiaire de sciences po kenza qui nous
a beaucoup accompagné là dessus qu'ils
étaient venus au comité d'éthique pour
travailler je ne sais pas sur quoi et
qui le vendredi
le vendredi 13 je le dis kenza est ce
qu'il ya des trains est ce que tu sais
prendre des trains qui passent elle m'a
dit oui et n'a pas arrêté travailler
avec nous merci à dieu merci monsieur le
président alors avant de passer la
parole à monsieur rapporteur je vous
interroger sur deux points de manière
rétrospective
l'om est déclaré le 30 janvier 2020 l'
urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale
considérez vous que l'installation du
conseil scientifique dont vous venez
nous expliquer à la fois le
fonctionnement et la teneur et les
décisions le 11 mars est intervenue
suffisamment tôt ensuite le 20 mars vous
déclariez dans un entretien au journal
le monde que si la france n'avait pas
suivi une stratégie de dépistage aussi
active que dans d'autres pays comme la
corée du sud ou l'allemagne c'est je
vous cite tout simplement parce que nous
en sommes incapables
auriez vous préconisez un dépistage
systématique de la population si nous en
avions eu les moyens et est il
aujourd'hui avéré qu'une telle politique
aurait permis de ralentir
significativement pardon l'épidémie
ou pure était ce dépistage eu tout à
l'heure je laisserais bruno bruno répond
sur la date de l'installation c'est très
difficile je je vous ai expliqué que moi
même je m'étais réveillé si je peux dire
relativement tard autour du autour du 20
février que associant sur quatre points
cette réunion à l'om est à genève qui
m'avait beaucoup troublé
alors que j'étais pour les
considérations éthiques en tant que
président du conseil national d'éthique
à l'époque sur de l'épidémie mais
j'avais été très frappé par le fait que
les chinois ne répondait absolument
aucune question je dirais de façon
sérieuse alors qu' il y avait des 60
experts mondiaux de situation de crise
qui étaient rassemblés
le deuxième élément c'est ce qui se
passait en italie j'ai beaucoup de
copains en italie du nord contrairement
à ce qu'on abat la présentation de
l'italie pays moins développés sur le
plan médical que la france est
entièrement faux ils ont des équipes qui
sont de très haut niveau
et le fait est de très très haut niveau
ils ont même une interaction avec les
états unis qui est bien meilleur que le
nôtre et le fait qu'ils soient dépassées
avec une série de coups la feuille de
coups de téléphone que j'avais donné ma
fait dire que voilà celle ci s'était
passé on serait dépassé le le troisième
le troisième élément et c'était les
premiers retours de nos collègues
réanimateur et lille à dire à tout à
l'heure que la situation était déjà très
tendu à partir de fin mars 2,2 fin
février étaient anormalement tendu en
tout cas et puis le quatrième le
quatrième élément était les premiers
contacts avec les modélisateurs qui sont
un des éléments on y reviendra qui on
doit pas les prendre pour argent
comptant mais on doit également les
écouter il est confronté à la réalité du
terrain
donc tout ça pour dire que oui il aurai
je ne sais pas en tout cas si si le
conseiller est ce que nous aurions
mamelles été nommé trois quatre jours ou
cinq jours avant est ce que nous aurions
été capables
je dirais de transmettre des
informations suffisamment
fiable solide et est appuyée pour que le
pouvoir politique prenne une décision de
ce type c'est c'est pas facile et c'est
ça ne s'est jamais produit si on regarde
les dates dont au niveau européen des
différents pays en terme de
de confinement vous voyez que la france
voit là se situe se situe à un niveau
jeudi à l'intermédiaire bon comme que et
en plus
n'attendons pas non plus du comité
scientifique on avait une série d'
agences en france aussi qui étaient déjà
présentes
donc je ne peux pas aller plus loin sur
le problème du des du dépistage
oui ou non ce que j'ai voulu indiquer
mais on vous le redire à tout à l'heure
c'est que on a appris un quand on était
à l'elysée le 12 et entre nous parce que
et bruno nous a donné un certain nombre
d'informations que le nombre de tests de
diagnostic rt pcr disponible est réalisé
chaque jour à ce moment là était de
l'ordre de 3 à 4000 ce qu'ils étaient et
leur que même on avait des données qui
montrait qu'en allemagne le nombre de
tests étaient déjà plus important depuis
depuis plus longtemps donc y compris
dans la stratégie avoir ces voix là on
peut dire il faut hurler dire qu'il faut
beaucoup plus de tests on l'a fait on a
demandé qu'il y ait plus de tests donc
ce n'est même occupé avec bruno on a été
un tout petit peu opérationnels à ce
moment là mais il faut aussi voir la
réalité de ce qu'on est et on avait on
avait la capacité de faire 3000 ou 4000
test à ce moment là donc c'est ce que
j'ai voulu indiquer en disant qu'il y
avait une stratégie qui avait été monté
pendant le mois de janvier le mois de
février qui ne laissait pas une place à
l'utilisation des tests de façon plus
globale que le que le tracking des
clusters qui avait été parfaitement fait
et qui n'était pas répandue de façon
plus large dans la population et enfin
arnaud vous dira sûrement tout à l'heure
que tout ça c'est joué quand même un peu
de chose que de toute façon nous aurions
eu la pandémie en france mais qu'elle
aurait été peut-être moins importante
si on n'avait pas eu d'épisode de
mulhouse lle a probablement en dise est
fait de supers contamination qu'on ne
connaissait pas bien à l'époque
et puis je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle quand même c'est quelque chose
de très particulier sur lequel on n'a
pas de vraie compréhension qu'en france
comme d'ailleurs vous prenez en
allemagne comme en angleterre comme en
italie comme en espagne on parle de deux
d'espagne de france etc
mais c'est totalement faux on voit bien
qu'en france il ya quatre grandes
régions qui font 70 % de la mortalité
c'est la même chose d'ailleurs en
angleterre c'est la même chose en italie
avec cette différence entre le nord et
le sud donc il ya bien des choses qu'on
ne comprend pas bien qui ce qu'ils
peuvent être on y reviendra tout à
l'heure et qui montre qu'il ya des
hétérogénéités régionales qui se sont
produites qui ne se seraient
probablement pas resté là où l'épidémie
aurait été sur l'ensemble mais où le
confinement a permis de les bloquer ce
niveau là mais pourquoi il ya eu et il
s'est dit il c'est ces disparités
initiale de niveau région en france
comme ailleurs c'est des vrais questions
autour des villes etc et qui sont des
vrais grande question qui n'est pas ce
sanitaires monsieur le président madame
messieurs sûr d'abord est ce que vous
avez vraiment en conscience d'être une
question difficile ou incongrues le
sentiment de l'utilité de ce conseil
scientifique
dire cela c'est poser la question de la
comparaison avec des situations
internationales est ce qu'une instance
analogue à exister a été mise en oeuvre
dans cette situation de crise dans
d'autres pays
une question aussi sur la concurrence la
compétition ou du moins plus
prosaïquement la coexistence avec des
autorités sanitaires qui étaient des
institutions sanitaires qui étaient déjà
installés et dont on a eu un peu le
sentiment de la disparition ou quelque
part de de la confusion
le haut conseil de la santé publique la
haute autorité de santé vous évoquez la
création du comité caire on a eu un peu
le sentiment que ces instants se
multiplier qu' on en crée d'autres pour
coordonner la coordination et que cela
crée sans doute une forme aussi de
confusion et on en vient
et vous l'avez posez vous même sur la
question de la gouvernance de la
gouvernance peut-être
au niveau central mais également de la
gouvernance territoriale et je le dis là
si en tant qu'élu local
on a eu sur le terrain le sentiment je
présidais longtemps département je suis
encore notamment sur la question des
ehpad qui avait un énorme déficit de
gouvernance pendant plusieurs semaines
sur les ehpad on n'a pas eu les
instructions fait défaut les équipements
aussi la position de la drs était pas
clair j'ai vécu personnellement 39 morts
dans un établissement mougins où le
président du département a demandé la
fermeture de cet établissement ont la
rsi est opposé donc on a eu aussi ce
sentiment et j'aimerais avoir votre
votre position sur la pertinence
aujourd'hui de cesser reste ans régional
et ses autorités qui sont loin aussi de
la proximité dans une période de crise
donc on a un échelon national qui fixe
une stratégie à un échelon local qui est
censée la mettre en oeuvre mais on a au
nas cette difficulté puis pour conclure
mon propos mais nos collègues ont posé
beaucoup de questions vous avez j'ai été
marqué par votre interview d'autres ont
été cités du 7 juin dans le jdd où le
titre mais c'est peut-être votre parole
c'est souvent la règle chez les
journalistes et nous le savons bien ici
disait laissons les gens vivre comprend
ce message mais ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
frappé dans cette interview vous
rappeliez les journées difficiles vous
l'avez fait 12 13 et 14 mars
c'était sur la position et la décision
du confinement vous indiquiez l'avoir
proposé je vous cite nous assumons le
fait d'avoir proposé
le confinement dans ces trois journées
difficiles ce n'était pas notre décision
car la partie en politique vous l'avez
rappelé et là je crois qu on est au
coeur de tout ce qui finalement doit
nous guider et vous dit ce n'était pas
une bonne décision mais la moins
mauvaise étant donné les outils que nous
avions et vous rajoutiez 3000 test par
jour quand les allemands en avaient plus
de 50 donc en conscience aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que ce
confinement aurait put elle aurait pu
être évitée pardon et est-ce qu'ils
pourraient être évités si par malheur
demain à l'automne ou plus tard deuxième
vague de même ampleur ou plus forte
venait à venait à arriver on a vu dans
l'histoire ancienne et je sais pas si si
la comparaison à une valeur scientifique
vous pourrez nous le dira mais on
évoquer la grippe espagnole qui ses
revenus ou la deuxième vague a été plus
violente
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour que nous soyons pour que nous
soyons prêts sur les équipements de
protection sur les tests sur les masques
sur le dépistage sur la capacité
d'accueil en service de réanimation
voilà sept cette mauvaise décision mais
la moins mauvaise comment on peut la
feue la transformer avec une gouvernance
renouvelée en bonne en bonne décision
merci en tout cas de de votre présence
ici vous aurez
londres deux premières questions puis je
laisserais peut-être arnaud fontanet ou
sûr parce que il faut qu'on alterne que
vous voyez une fois de plus que nous
avons une construction commune sur vous
répondre sur le confinement à la fois y
avait-il d'autres décisions possibles et
qu'est ce que nous envisagions sur
sursis si on devait avoir une deuxième
fois qu'on l'a déjà peut annoncer dans
le nôtre dans notre avis est sûre les
scénarios mais on va y revenir
alors sur l'utilité du conseil
scientifique écoutez moi je sais que
c'est très difficile on fait partie du
concept bon mais moi vous savez j'ai ma
carrière allait fait je suis un vieux
monsieur
donc j'ai je je je me protégerait
d'ailleurs s'il ya six à une deuxième
vague
ce que j'ai dit par rapport à mes petits
enfants puisque je vois que vous lisez
je les tenues un jeu pour l'instant je
les ai vus à travers le balcon ou loin
mais j'ai pas eu des jeunes et de
familles ont club c'est toujours
extrêmement difficiles je sais si
finalement j'ai dis pas qu'on va
justifier on a été créé il ya 2 et les
trois éléments sur lesquels j'ai déjà
insisté
le premier c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
dépendance hiérarchique des membres du
conseil scientifique par rapport au
ministre par rapport aux aux autorités
politiques et par rapport aux grandes
instances ce qui laisse une liberté de
parole qui est quelque chose d'essentiel
le le deuxième le deuxième élément c'est
la multidisciplinarité qui n'est pas si
évidente dans la construction française
y compris dans les aspects recherche y
compris c'est à dire cette
transversalité de la construction et qui
qui se fait non pas autour d'un homme ou
d'une femme mais qui se fait avec une
construction de groupe et qui est
un exercice d'intelligence collective et
qui m'apparaît essentiel est essentielle
il n'y a pas de grand sauveur ça
n'existe pas il ya de l'intelligence
collective à la française qui peut et
qui est qui montre on a cette capacité
là je l' ai connu dans dans la lutte
contre le vih et avec une communauté
française qui a été au plus haut niveau
et bien voilà il faut il faut qu'on
reste sur les maladies émergentes
autour d'eux autour de cette vision là
est la troisième bien c'est le fait que
les les avis ou les notes que nous avons
produites soit il s'agissait de
commandes de l'état et vous avez à juste
titre et on pourra y revenir si vous
voulez évoqué l'idée des élections qui
est vital qu'ils aient quelque chose
d'un peu compliqué y compris dans notre
tête
bon mais aussi on pouvait s'autosaisir
vous savez quand on s'autosaisit vous le
savez bien eh bien on est maître du
monde puisqu'on peut aborder n'importe
quel problème et le poser sur la table
il faut bien en face de soi qui est une
une réaction du politique au sens au
sens général du terme donc
l'auto-saisine et ça je pense mais il
sut pas mes collègues appuieront pas au
contraire mais des abron que peut-être
des agences de l'état qui ont à
construire qui ont des dents dans une
certaine mesure à justifier lagence a
justifié ce qu'elles ont fait ce
qu'elles n'ont pas fait ce qu'elles vont
faire les moyens qu'elles vont avoir à
discuter avec le ministère des finances
le ministère de la recherche au
ministère de la santé à partir du mois
de juillet le nombre de tp qu'elles vont
qu'elles vont perdre
nous non pas du tout c'est le dernier
point en effet c'est qu'il faut que ce
soit quelque chose de transitoire il ya
un début une fin et on passe à autre
chose et je voulais même je m'avance un
peu mais imaginons qu'ils aient une
deuxième vague et qu'on la loi de crise
sanitaire
se remettre mais tombe à partir de à
partir de fin octobre et de recréer un
conseil scientifique
il m'apparaîtrait 5 se soit pas le même
il m'apparaît très très sympa qui est
probablement de trois personnes qui
restent pour avoir une sorte de
transition
mais sur le fond il faudrait changer il
faudrait avoir une vision un peu
différente
plusieurs plusieurs questions on y sent
sur ce que vous avez évoqué d'abord la
première chose sans poser stricto sensu
une question sur les masques est-ce que
la stratégie que vous avez définies vous
avez suggéré à l'exécutif qui en a
ensuite décidé a été ou non déterminée
par la disponibilité des masques la
disponibilité des tests notamment
et s'agissant des tests il nous a été
dit hier dans madame chen qu'au fond le
test pcr avait été mis au point très
rapidement par l'institut pasteur
sauf que j'ai mal compris que mi-mai on
disposait d'un test et entre mi-mai et
finalement le la mise en place effective
des tests et encore plus la
massification on a le sentiment qui
s'est passé je sais ce que j'ai mal
compris on dit on a dit mi janvier 7
janvier ses 17 janvier voilà 10 janvier
saisine de l'institut pasteur et du bon
et donc finalement ça va assez vite puis
après on attend que ça va pas ça peuvent
pas vite du tout donc voilà est ce que
c'est les moyens ont déterminé la
stratégie première chose
et puis d'autres votre audition
professeur delfraissy que vous aviez dit
que par rapport à nos capacités de
l'allemagne vers des leçons à en tirer
pour la france j'aimerais savoir quelles
sont les leçons que l'on peut en tirer
deuxième chose avait évoqué la question
de la gouvernance et c'est vrai que dans
la constitution du conseil scientifique
on a pu s'interroger de ce qu'elle se
soit une nécessité
fondée sur une insuffisance de notre
système notre expertise en place et
notamment de santé publique france alors
vous avez un peu répandu mais est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que même si vous
avez dit que ça devait être
nécessairement transitoire un conseil
scientifique mais que d'une certaine
manière c'était un outil qui manquait et
qui mériterait par la suite d'être
pérennisé sous une forme ou sous une
autre
confinement nationale versus régional en
fait avoir fait un confinement nationale
a permis aux régions qui n'était pas
encore touché de ne pas l'être et on
savait que c'était quand même un virus
qui avait une capacité de propagation
extrêmement rapide et je comprends la
situation a pu être un peu étrange pour
des l'ouest de la france globalement où
le virus a très peu circulé mais
finalement en figeant la situation 15
mars avec le 17 mars avec un confinement
nationale on a permis aux zones qui
étaient préservés de le rester je pense
que ça aurait été difficile de l'assuré
haut niveau qui aurait permis une
diffusion et je pense qu'aussi le
confinement a permis de reconstruire les
éléments de la période de sortie qui
était absolument nécessaire au 15 mai
pour pouvoir aborder le moment où vous
ça y est les gens pourraient à nouveau
ressortir de chez eux et aussi reculé
mais l'expérience qu'on a en tout cas du
blocage des frontières par exemple on
sait très bien que le blocage des
frontières ne marche pas parce que les
gens qu'on tourne et on gagne en général
5 à 10 jours sur la propagation d'une
épidémie avec le blocage d'une frontière
et je pense que à l'échelon à
l'intérieur d'un pays il est encore plus
facile de contourner que de le faire
pour franchir une frontière je me trompe
peut-être
mais en tout cas je n'aurais pas pris de
risque et je crois que le fait d'avoir
confiné d'emblée à l'échelle nationale a
permis finalement de préserver les
régions de l'ouest de la france et de
leur éviter de vivre une épidémie de la
même façon que les pays d'europe journée
à la dessus qui ont confiné au 15 mars
comme pas seulement l'allemagne compte
beaucoup
mais le danemark la norvège la finlande
l'autriche la hongrie l'estonie la grèce
le portugal ont tous éviter une épidémie
et je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même très important et
qu'il faut bien bien retenir donc de ce
côté là je crois que c'était un choix
qui était sage et qui finalement a été
payant puisque ça à éviter que
l'épidémie gagne le reste de la france
monsieur à battre s'il vous plaît vous
me demander la parole je préfèrerais
qu'on laisse les réponses et je viendrai
puisque vous avez posé la question je
reviendrai là dessus 2e deuxième élément
les écoles que sait-on les écoles c'est
extrêmement difficile
le modèle de la grippe qui est un modèle
différent nous avez appris effectivement
que des écoles sont des foyers très
important de transmission une
propagation des épidémies grippales
maintenant on savait qu'on n'était pas
face à la grippe et moi même ayant
travaillé sur le sera son volume 3 je me
souvenais très bien que pour le corps un
navire ou du strass en 2003 les enfants
n'avaient pas été touchés sans qu'on
n'ait jamais pu dire à l'époque parce
qu'il n'y avait eu que huit mille cas
dans le monde
on n'était pas devant une épidémie qui a
fait des dizaines de millions de cas
comme celle d'aujourd'hui on avait pu
étudier que 8000 cas dans le monde pour
le corps navires us traces mais on sait
je me souvenais très bien que des
enfants n'avaient été que très peu
touchée et que la question c'est est
toujours posée de savoir si les enfants
n'aient pas été tués ce qui n'était pas
exposé parce que c'était les adultes
soit parce que c'était des soignants
soit des personnes qui travaillaient
dans des zones qui étaient exposés
qu'ils avaient été infectés et ça devait
était resté dans un coin de la tête et
quand l'épidémie a redémarré avec ce
nouveau corps d'un virus ma première
question c'est est quel rôle les enfants
vont jouer dans la transmission
avec bien entendu en filigrane la le
rôle que pourraient jouer les fermetures
des écoles les premiers éléments dont on
a disposé n'était pas simple à
interpréter
très vite on a su que les enfants
faisait des formes mineures de la
maladie que très heureusement et
moi-même qui super de quatre ans
on savait que des enfants quand ils
étaient infectées soit fort et des
formes asymptomatiques soit des formes
mineures de la maladie mais heureusement
très rarement des formes graves dont
vous avez entendu parler mais qui reste
quand même vraiment l'exception et
j'insiste là dessus
en revanche sur est ce que des enfants
peuvent être affectés et ce qu'ils
peuvent être contagieux très peu
d'éléments
est ce qu'ils peuvent être affectés on a
des données discordantes quand vous
regardez dans les familles
et ça c'est des connaissances qui sont
accumulées depuis maintenant trois mois
mais qui n'existaient pas au 12 mars
on sait maintenant que finalement la
probabilité d'être affecté au sein d'une
famille quand un adulte arrive qu'il est
infecté est la même pour tous les
membres de la famille y compris les
enfants mais je parle de trois études
seulement je parle pas de corpus de
littérature qui s'appuie sur une
cinquantaine de publications
en revanche quand vous faites des
enquêtes transversale en population sans
vous intéressez à la cellule familiale
mais en population là on voit qu'ils
enfants sont moins souvent affectées
ivresse au volant parce qu'ils sont
moins souvent exposés donc soit le virus
arrive par le lien familial et là des
enfants peuvent être affectés et au même
titre que tous les autres membres de la
famille soit le virus notre pas par la
famille mais les gens sont exposés dans
le milieu professionnel ou ailleurs et c
est finalement les enfants eux sont
protégés c'est ce qu'on voit dans les
enquête de prévalence où la proportion
d'enfants infectés sont plus faibles
les enfants maintenant est ce qu'ils
peuvent pas affecter les autres alors
dans les études familiale qui ont été
menés on s'est rendu compte que quand on
testait des enfants on retrouvait des
pcr positif chez des enfants qui
n'avaient aucun symptôme des symptômes
mineurs mais ils gardaient le virus
pendant huit à dix jours dans la gorge
et ils exploitaient du virus dans les
selles jusqu'à un mois
on sait aujourd'hui que le virus etc ce
traité dans les salles et probablement
pas contagieux c'est peut-être des
débris génétique mais c'est pas du virus
viable contagieux mais ça a été une
inquiétude au début en revanche le virus
qu'ils ont dans la gorge
c'est un virus potentiellement
contagieux il ya deux équipes celle de
christian gross tonnes en allemagne qui
est une des équipes les plus réputées au
monde
et puis une équipe suisse qui en
mesurant les charges virales dans la
gorge des enfants ont retrouvé les mêmes
trois centration virale dans la gorge
des enfants que chez les adultes
il ya d'autres études mais elles sont
très peu nombreuses
4 sur les doigts de la main est une que
l'on avait pu citer le 12 mars que je
n'ai pas cité mais qui était dans les
choux médecine qui est une revue comme
très réputé qui montre effectivement que
des
et là aussi il y avait des
concentrations virale chez les enfants
qui n'est pas différent des adultes donc
on se retrouve dans cette situation on
apprend que les enfants font des formes
très peu symptomatiques
mais que malgré tout ils ont du jury
dans la gorge à des concentrations
similaire à celle des adultes est donc
très peu d'éléments pour nous dire
qu'ils ne vont pas être contagieux pour
leur entourage
ça c'était le 12 mars et c'est ce qui
les a guidés dans notre décision de
proposer un avis pour dire les écoles
pourraient représenter un lieu de
propagation du virus
et c'était ça qui nous a guidés ensuite
les données sont venus peu nombreuses je
mettrai d'un côté des études auxquelles
nous avons des dans lesquelles nous
avons été directement impliqué avec
l'institut pasteur à crépy en valois où
on s'est rendu compte que dans un lycée
une épidémie avait touché des lycéens
très largement 38 % des lycéens ont été
affectés
43% des enseignants 59% des personnels
non enseignants c'étaient les quinze
premiers jours de février
c'est une étude rétrospective on a fait
un dépistage sérologique
fin mars on a interrogé tout le monde
sur les symptômes et on a reconstruit la
courbe épidémique
donc on sait que chez les lycéens le
virus est capable de se transmettre
comme chez les adultes
vraisemblablement les hisser lycéens
sont des adolescents et de fait dans les
manifestations cliniques de la maladie
qu'il faut et dans la contagiosité
qu'ils ont assez proche des adultes et
donc je pense que pour les lycéens est
vrai sans les collégiens il faut rester
extrêmement prudent parce que en tout
cas on a cet exemple d'une épidémie qui
a très bien circuler dans un lycée dans
les écoles primaires ou élémentaire et
maternelle
il n'y a pas eu à ma connaissance une
seule d'épidémie décrite où que ce soit
dans le monde dont le foyer était une
école primaire une école maternelle fins
alimentaires ou maternelle
nous avons mené cette même enquête à
crépy en valois et les résultats
devraient très prochainement publiés qui
nous laisse entendre qu'il ya pas eu de
diffusion dans les écoles primaires
comme on aurait pu le redouter mais
surtout on s'appuie sur des études
internationales qui ont été menées qui
sont une étude en australie cinq écoles
primaires où il ya eu des introductions
d'enfants affectés sans cas secondaires
en irlande où ils sont retournés sur
tous les enfants affectés pour voir s'il
avait transmis dominos colorés n'aurait
retrouvé
et puis reste l'exemple des contaminants
france où un enfant de 9
symptomatique est allé dans trois écoles
devaient affecter personnes donc pour
l'instant sur les écoles primaires les
compétents et scientifiques que nous
avons sont plutôt rassurantes
il n'y a pas de risque zéro comme vous
le savez mais on a l'impression que les
enfants sont peu contagieux entre peu
contagieux pour leurs enseignants et que
de ce côté là un assouplissement des
règles qui a été proposée d'ailleurs
dans le contexte des écoles élémentaires
me paraît raisonnable au vu des données
dont on dispose donc c'est simplement
pour vous dire aussi que ce que je vous
ai résumé ici c'est trois mois de
recherches et c'est quelque chose qui
s'est construit petit à petit que le 12
mars vous pouvez relire la vie qu'on
avait proposé ce jour là parce qu'on a
incité les publications scientifiques
dont on ne disposait et qu'il était
effectivement très difficile ce jour là
de faire ce choix qui est d'ailleurs été
repris par l'ensemble des pays européens
en tout cas qui n'est aussi parce qu on
était tous dans une certaine assise dans
la certitude maintenant avec la période
qui c'est qui qui s'annonce je serais
vraiment prudent du côté des collèges et
des lycées du fait de ce qu'on a pu
mettre en évidence mais je dois dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'autres études
publiées à ce jour d'un lycée où le
virus est transmis donc on a peut-être
eu un phénomène tout à fait exceptionnel
au lycée de crépy en valois dont je peux
pas vous expliquer pourquoi il a eu lieu
là et pas ailleurs et qu en revanche sur
les écoles chez moins de 10 ans on a le
sentiment quand même que la transmission
beaucoup plus faible c'est aussi
corroboré par des études qui ont été
faites par les pédiatres français vous
savez robert cohen notamment l'étude en
islande et serrage des publicités donc
ça c'était le point sur les écoles et
vous partager avec vous ce qu'on sait
puisqu'on ne sait pas et il ya toujours
des choses qu'on ne sait pas il y avait
le point sur les masques alors la
transmission de ce virus a été pour nous
également
vraiment un point d'interrogation on
était parti à nouveau comme sur le corps
d'un virus du sras ce qui était
finalement l'exemple qu'on connaissait
le mieux sur un modèle d'un virus à
transmission respiratoire par des
gouttelettes
ce qui veut dire que quand vous projeter
des gouttelettes vous pouvez toucher
quelqu'un à une distance de 20 m
d'où la nécessité de porter un masque
pour éviter d'émettre ces gouttelettes
ou pour la personne de mettre en place
qui au mois protégera le nez et la
bouche pour éviter que les gouttelettes
nom dessus et puis si les gouttelettes
tombe sur des surfaces eh bien ils
viennent des mains est très importante
parce que si vous ramassez virus
vous pouvez après en touchant votre main
vos yeux vos bouches ce qu'on a beaucoup
l'habitude de faire et que j'ai
désappris à faire mais qui est quand
même très difficile
vous pouvez vous affectez donc ça c'est
le modèle gouttelettes et puis le strass
nous avait appris que les personnes
était contagieuse que 3 à 4 jours après
le début des symptômes et c'est ce qui
nous a permis de contrôler le strass
parce que les gens étaient
symptomatiques
pendant trois jours avec de la fièvre de
la toux pas encore contagieux s'il était
diagnostiquée il pouvait être isolé et
il n'avait pas encore contaminé d'autres
personnes et c'est grâce à ça qu'on l'a
arrêté comme un virus du strass et mon
secret espoir quand cette épidémie a
démarré et ex nouveau comme un virus se
comporte de la même façon
malheureusement en février première
publication qui nous arrive
nous apprenons qu'ils auraient eu des
transmissions chez des gens qui
n'étaient pas encore symptomatique
la première publication la regarde
toujours d'une façon critique quand vous
remettez en cause a dog à la fois en
tant que scientifique moi c'est ce qui
me passionne c'est toujours de me
remettre en question et de me dire tiens
c'est pas pareil c'est intéressant mais
on est critique et d'ailleurs la
publication du new england journal of
medecine a été critiquée des gens disant
que la personne qui était censé ne pas
avoir de symptômes en fait avait des
symptômes qu'elle avait été mal
interrogé ça a été toute une polémique
dans le milieu des scientifiques qui a
duré 15 jours
mais d'autres publications sont venus et
il est devenu avéré vers la fin février
que des transmissions à la période très
symptomatique donc avant le
développement des symptômes étaient
possibles on a même en prix entre temps
que des gens pouvaient faire des
infections s'en présentait aucun
symptôme et on pense qu'ils peuvent être
contagieux probablement moi parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de symptômes
tout ceci donc nous remet un peu en
cause par rapport à notre dog et comme
je le disais si le sera cette fois de
contrôler parce qu'on était contagieux
seulement après le début des symptômes
et parce que tout le monde avec le
strass faisait des formes symptomatiques
on se retrouve devant un virus qui est
transmissible avant le début des
symptômes avec des gens qui peuvent même
ne présentait aucun symptôme ou des
symptômes mineurs et son contrôle
devient extrêmement difficile et c'est
là évidemment que les masques monte en
puissance
parce qu'on se dit à ce moment-là que
effectivement si les gens peuvent
n'avoir aucun symptôme être contagieux
il faut que tout le monde portent des
masques pour protéger les autres parce
que si vous êtes prêt symptomatique vous
pouvez mettre des gouttelettes
et vous vous protégez en face et
l'importance du masque vraiment à ce
moment-là devenir beaucoup plus évidente
là où les choses se sont encore
compliquées c'est quand on s'est rendu
compte que ce virus était en
concentration extrêmement élevée dans le
fond de la gorge jusqu'à 1000 fois
supérieure aux concentrations qu'on peut
rencontre on avait avec le corps un
virus du sras ce qui est un virus qui
était au fond des poumons et dès lors
les personnes qui sont porteuses de ce
nouveau corner virus avec des
concentrations mille fois supérieure à
celle que d'autres virus respiratoires
ont dans le fond de la gorge sont
capables d'émettre des quantités très
importantes y compris en parlant et
c'est là qu'interviennent un nouveau
mode de propagation qui est encore pas
prouvée mais qui devient de plus en plus
plausible qui est celui de la
transmission par ce qu'on appelle les
aérosols
c'est à dire que des particules qui font
seulement quelques microns de diamètre
tout petits qui restent en suspension
dans l'air qui tombent pas immédiatement
qu'ils peuvent rester douze 12 heures en
suspension dans l'air peuvent contenir
un ou plusieurs virus alors qu'elles
sont de quelques microns de diamètre
seulement parce que vous avez des
concentrations extrêmes de ce virus dans
le fond de la gorge
et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on n'avait
pas avec le grand navire u6 traces
l'ensemble du conseil scientifique
considère que compte le contenu de ce
qui se passe dans l'hémisphère sud de
l'ensemble des particularités de ce
virus qui est un cornaro mais qui
ressemble finalement ce qui est en jeu
ce qui s'est passé avec un virus grippal
considère que le risque d'une deuxième
vague une vraie deuxième bague pas d'une
réapparition venant de l'hémisphère sud
et revenant sur sur le nord et en
particulier en europe
fin octobre ou en novembre ou en
décembre est un risque qui doit être
considérée ceci a été annoncé aux
autorités politiques de ce pays
notre position là dessus et donc il faut
le préparer et ne pas se retrouver dans
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
trouvés le 12 mars
et c'est bien là l'enjeu finalement 2
comment faire pour que
on ne revive pas le 12 mars le deuxième
point du conseil scientifique et de
considérer qu'un confinement généralisée
tel qu'il a été mis en place le 12 mars
ne sera pas ni possible ni ne sera
souhaitable ni pour aller au fond des
choses ne serait accepté par la
population française pour de multiples
raisons
on met souvent les raisons économiques
au début ils ne sont pas seulement
économiques
elles sont également d'ordre sociétal
elles sont et c'est une question qui se
posera et qui va se poser pour vous les
politiques de comment à ce moment là
faire pour probablement expliqué tenté
d'expliquer à nos populations qu'il va y
avoir une population jeune qui a peu de
risque qui peut travailler qui peut
aller à l'école pour les plus jeunes qui
peut continuer à travailler en prenant
l'ensemble des des précautions et en
étant évidemment extrêmement stricte 1
mais qui on laisse finalement une
certaine forme de vie qui s'installe et
de l'autre côté des populations plus
âgées plus à risque qu'ils falloir
protéger alors pas les protéger malgré
elle mais en étant quand même même si de
nouveaux m'accuse je dirais de vouloir
ostracisé cette population dont je fais
partie donc je suis assez à l'aise et
bien si ça devait se produire
il faudrait conseiller toujours avec
leur acceptation à cette population plus
fragiles et bien d'avoir des confirmands
partiels mais qui serait évidemment plus
important
monsieur le professeur delfraissy
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
conseil scientifique également à
m'associer à mes collègues pour vous
remercier pour prendre le risque de vous
exposer comme ça alors qu'on a
l'habitude d'être dans le travail ou de
cliniciens ou de chercheurs est que et
que c'est un risque sur ajouter un peu
compliqué parfois à devoir gérer
notamment pour tous ceux et notamment je
pense que les politiques sont coupables
de ce côté là de penser qu'on a toujours
un consensus scientifique et qu'on n'a
pas le droit de changer d'avis et de se
remettre en question ce qui est plutôt
sain dans notre métier comme un comédien
comme chercheur et qui est peu compris
en politique on a l'habitude d'avoir des
assertions un petit peu facile donc face
à cela il ya eu quand même des les
étapes un peu difficile à comprendre
pour les gens puisque certains disent et
blanc de 10 et noir et à des
chronologies différentes notamment sur
les sur les tests par exemple ou sur les
masques on a souvent eu l'impression que
du côté politique on y est l'importance
de certaines stratégies plus tôt pour
expliquer enfin pour vous justifier le
les manquements et moi j'ai cru
comprendre monsieur delfraissy que vous
en tout cas vous sembliez convaincu très
tôt tout début mars de l'importance de
cet ace massif on était là encore dix
jours avant avant les annonces de tedros
à l' oms et en dix jours avant le même
moment où jérôme salomon dit que ça n'a
aucun intérêt de tester a massivement
pendant la période aiguë propagation de
la maladie je voudrais que vous me
préciser sur 7 sur 7 sur ce point et
ensuite sur les questions de je vous ai
pas beaucoup entendu au moment où est le
scandale sur le land set et là
j'aimerais juste savoir ce que ce que
vous ce que vous pensez ou ce que vous
avez exprimé c'est le plus conseillé au
président de la république ou ou au
ministre la santé moi je ne sais
toujours pas ce jeu mené une partie
investigations en direct c'est moi qui
ai identifié l'employé fictifs qui était
censé être directrice des ventes et qui
était dame qui faisait des photos de
charme
on a dit on atterrit sur le fil de
mensonges comme dirait l'autre on a
trouvé que les autres choses si l'on
pouvait revenir au sujet moi je voudrais
savoir si c'est le sujet parce que à ce
moment là il ya des choses graves et des
décisions au niveau international qui
ont été prises de rothbach est des
études sur les drogues si chloroquine
puis deux reprises puis aujourd'hui
d'arrêt pour d'autres raisons
qu'est ce que vous avez eu comme
information est ce qu'il ya des données
ethniques qui ont été utilisés sur les
patients français comme s'était dit dans
dans cet étudiant dans celle du new
england
est-ce qu'elle a été collectée est ce
qu'elles sont fantasmer est ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle exige
est ce que vous avez eu des informations
précises sur les patients français qui
auraient été échantillonnée pour une
dossier deux études ou est ce que tout
ça est fantôme cette société tels
fantôme tout ça est il fictifs qui est
derrière cette escroquerie j'aimerais
vous please répondre puisque on n'a pas
eu encore les réponses du ministre la
santé ou du dgs sur cette question merci
je n'avais plus assez monsieur
penchèrent pardon excusez moi je préside
le conseil scientifique est créée par le
président de la république début mars
alors qu'il existe déjà des instances
scientifiques structures et vous l'avez
vous l'avez rappelé notre groupe avait
relevé les difficultés pour une instance
de ce type créée ex nihilo et avait
d'ailleurs demandé qu'on s'appuie sur
des structures existantes comme le haut
conseil pour la santé publique votre
structure est constitué de personnalités
très compétente vous avez mais vous avez
rendu des avis parfois tardif est aussi
hélas après que les décisions politiques
été rendu lorsque le président de la
république s'adresse aux français le 12
mars vous ne vous êtes réuni qu'une
seule fois avant pour votre installation
le président fait des annonces lourd de
conséquences mais vous ne rendez public
que votre avis le lendemain de son
intervention soit le 13 mars le 15 avril
vous vous rendez à la convocation de
notre mission d'information sur le
coronavirus nous apprenons ainsi que les
français que vous prenez quelque peu vos
distances sur la sortie généralisée du
confinement le 11 mai vous nous l'avez
rappelé il m'était apparu aussi que
votre conseil n'était pas favorable au
confinement total qui ai vu des débats
dans vos instances je vous demande lors
de cette audience si c'était le cas vous
n'avez pas répondu précisément je vous
écris quelques jours plus tard pour
repréciser me ma demande toujours pas de
réponse eu certain que cette non-réponse
un parlementaire membre de la mission
notre d'une mission de traces en blé
n'est dû qu'à une lourdeur des tâches
est une
aucune critique dessus sur ce sujet
ainsi que l'insuffisance de moyens du
conseil scientifique
en cette période de crise la confiance
dans les rouages de l'état est essentiel
c'est la clé de la réussite cependant
outre les absences de transparence dans
la gestion des masques et des tests il
ya eu quand même des questions de
méthode et a eu quand même des questions
de méthode
j'apprends par ailleurs par la presse
que vous avez demandé des moyens pour
créer un comité de liaison avec la
société je sais que vous défendez la
démocratie sanitaire
je partage cette vision mais pourriez
vous nous dire quels furent les manques
dans ce domaine est ce que vous précise
que vous préconisez pour l'avenir merci
si vous permettez j'aurais voulu donner
la parole à manawan pas parce que on a
eu une seule question sur les
respirateurs et sur la réanimation en
france et j'aimerais bien savoir comment
on abordera aussi la seconde phase qui
ensuite pour les réponses aux autres
questions partie
voulez que je vous parle des
respirateurs pardon hein comment nous
avons vu que les crises comment on va
faire pour la suite alors vous savez que
nos services de réanimation dans un 5000
lits qu'en fait c'est lisse on fait zéro
puisque s'ils sont occupés
habituellement et que on a eu la chance
de découvrir que pendant le confinement
est bien certain nombre de pathologies
qui diminuait même si le confinement a
eu des effets délétères
on a pu accueillir un grand nombre de
malades 7000 puisque le nombre de
malades qui arrivent habituellement dans
mon service a largement diminué mais
c'est cette lie ces sept mille lits il a
fallu ancrée 2002 plus et puis un petit
peu plus puisque certains quand même
patients sont quand même arrivés dans
nos services de réanimation alors
l'organisation il faut il réfléchir à
l'avancé pour la la prochaine vague
parce que ce qui s'est passé c'est que
chaque hôpitaux chaque structure de
soins a progressivement augmenté sa
capacité en trouvant des 10 dans des
structures qui ne sont pas adaptés à la
ranimation qu'on a rapidement essayé
d'adapter la réanimation ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut pas
renouveler et qu'on peut dès à présent
réfléchir à comment on ouvrira les lie
dans quel ordre dans quels hôpitaux à
quel endroit et les adapter dès
maintenant à des soins de réanimation
qui seront pas comme dans des services
de réanimation mais qui pourront être
bien meilleur sur les respirateurs je
peux je peux répondre un des
respirateurs bien évidemment on a failli
en montée dans mon service tous les
soirs se poser la question de savoir si
on pourrait ventiler le prochain malade
on a utilisé des ventilateurs de
domicile quoi mondial des sociétés
privées il ya un certain nombre de
ventilateurs qui ont été fabriqués qui
sont des ventilateurs de transport qui
ont été fabriqués en urgence mais qui
sont pas adaptés à la ventilation de
malades qui ont coronavirus à la phase
aiguë dont on pourrait penser quand même
qu'il pourrait avoir une utilité si un
grand nombre de malades arrivent en
réanimation puisque à un moment donné
ces patients sont en phase de sevrage de
la ventilation et qu'on peut
éventuellement mettre ce type de rance
de respirateurs mais ils sont quand même
pas d'un grand niveau
et puis surtout il ne suffit pas pour
faire de la réanimation d'avoir des
respirateurs on pourrait bien en avoir
dix mille trente mille il faut des gens
il faut des médecins il faut des
soignants il faut des bouteilles
d'oxygène et ça on ne l'a pas donc dix
mille ventilateur je ne vois pas très
bien moi personnellement comment on
aurait pu mettre le personnel derrière
sur les stocks de médicaments il ya eu
un flou pour les cliniciens au lit du
malade sur quel était l'état des stocks
comment ces stocks à les distribuer dans
mon hôpital
effectivement au bout d'un certain temps
tout était réquisitionnée et la façon
dont on allait obtenir les médicaments
n'était pas extrêmement clair on a fait
d'ailleurs des notes d' alerte sur ça
puisque l'incertitude pour un soignant
c'est un ajoute un livre de stress
supplémentaire
je ne sais pas répondre à la question de
savoir comment aujourd'hui les stocks
sont pourvus et comment ces stocks
compte est distribuée c'est une crise à
nouveau apparaît ce sur la pénurie d'un
certain nombre de médicaments de deux
types curare enfin deux destinés aux
malades en réanimation qui sont lille à
l'heure a plaidé mme attrait particulier
1 2 que vous avez d'ailleurs pas décrit
les chinois à l'om à 100 je pouvais être
clair c'est à dire ces patients très
lourd de trois semaines de ventilation
etc
les anglais ont eu le même problème
c'est pas pieux et on a été en contact
avec avec des collègues anglais de
milieu associatif c'est beaucoup bougé
sur le sujet y avec plusieurs plusieurs
notes d' alerte et que pour les pour le
mais qui au niveau européen c'est à dire
que il y a eu véritablement dans
différents pays parce que tout d'un coup
un temps donné en tout cas pour les pays
riches comme les nôtres permettant de
ventiler une série de nombreux patients
quelque chose qu'on n'avait jamais connu
c'est pas une ça veut dire qu'on peut
pas mieux faire il faut anticiper pour
le reste et ça ça pose aussi le problème
de la souveraineté mais c'est pas notre
objet là mais vous en entendrez sûrement
parler dans d'autres éditions delà de la
capacité de chacun des pays à pouvoir
fabriquer des produits de base pour ses
propres médicaments de
de nécessaire et c'est une vraie grande
question n'aviez plus rien à rajouter
monsieur ne se penchèrent mais c'est
pour ça sisi pas du tout je alors d'une
part bruno est ce que tu peux répondre
rapidement deux trois questions sur les
tests qui avaient été posées c'est à
dire la positionnement par rapport aux
tests c'est ce qui à d'autres types de
tests possibles voilà il ya eu ces deux
types de questions et puis j'ai bien
noté toutes vos questions
avec attention donc de pouvoir
oui les entraînements quand on parle de
test on parle de tests virologiques et
sur ce dont je parlerai pas des tests
sérologiques qui sont là des tests qui
sont en cours de déploiement et qui sont
complémentaires des tests virologiques
on cherche des alternatives pour avoir
des méthodes de palme en plus simple et
d'autres techniques de prélèvement
prévenant plus simple qui est premier le
premier testé c'est le prélèvement
salivaire
ce prélèvement salivaire pose des
problèmes méthodologiques pas de
collecte mais d'analystes c'est
compliqué d'analyser le contenu d'une
salive et c'est plus compliqué que de
l'analyse et le contenu d'un prélèvement
nasopharyngé classique mais c'est
beaucoup plus facile donc il ya des
travaux en cours la deuxième chose c'est
qu'on a des techniques qui évolue on a
du système qu'on appelle le lan pcr qui
sont de la pcr isotherme qui sont plus
rapides qui semble avoir les mêmes
capacités analytiques c'est à dire que
ça détecte aussi bien et c'est des
petits dispositifs mobiles qui
pourraient avoir une excellente
sensibilité et qui pourraient être
utilisés en biologie déportés et donc
complémenter les tests pcr et puis il ya
d'autres alternatives aussi qu'ils sont
des tests antigénique qui pour l'instant
n'existe pas ou ce qui existe en tout
cas son de qualité extrêmement médiocre
avec des taux de sensibilité de l'ordre
de 25 à 30 % dont conrad 70% des
patients ce qui n'est pas acceptable et
il y a après des travaux de recherche
sur d'autres types de tests
notamment sur air expiré ou autre la
philosophie sur les tests massif en fait
elle est vraie elle vous a été expliqué
tout à l'heure c'est vraiment l'idée
d'avoir une identification précise mais
ça doit être combiné avec les mesures
d'isolement et le contact racing pour
pouvoir casser les chaînes de
transmission
donc c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
très important et qu'il faudra activer
lors de la deuxième vague de façon
abondante ont une question sur le
scandale du lens est l'ancien guette
donc j'ai écouté non on n'a pas du tout
voilà vous n'avez d'autre d'autres
enjeux avec la vie cette je pense qui je
sors de là mois avec un certain malaise
je vous le cache pas parce que la
science la médecine de façon générale et
pas qu'en france contrairement à ce
qu'on dit sors de là quand même un peu
bousculés on aborde on a vu d'abord de
très nombreux non sachant devenir des
sachants sur les réseaux de télévision
divers et variés on a vu on a vu on a vu
des choses à des effets d'annoncé des
commentaires des gens continuent à en
voir enfin moi je vraiment on est au
dessus de ça c'est pas l'objet mais
c'est finalement j'ai un certain malaise
et où il va falloir qu'on resserre les
boulons là de façon importante pour que
une fois de plus la confiance avec les
français ce qui est quelque chose de
très fondamentale où on a un modèle
français de relation médecin patient qui
est bonne qui est bien supérieur au
million le saxon je pense que là elle a
été un peu touché je l'avais déjà perçu
dans les états généraux de la bioéthique
où il y avait une remise en cause d'un
certain nombre de la place de la
relation entre les entre les patients et
les médecins
et là je pense qu'il va falloir vraiment
qu'on reconstruise quelque chose de
cohérent et en étant inclusif en tenant
compte de tout ce qui s'est passé et en
étant exclusif sur sur le sujet mais que
c'est une s'éteint c'est un vrai point
ensuite vous sur la démocratie sanitaire
c'est un sujet où il est il à une heure
de l'après midi pour y passer parce que
c'est un subtil mais cher comme vous le
savez je crois que la con
truction dans ce problème très
particulier qui est la santé pour nos
concitoyens
elle se construit avec un triangle et ce
triangle lui comprend le politique et
vous même les les députés et les
sénateurs qui prenait les décisions qui
voter les lois
elle se construit avec les experts et
les médecins que nous sommes et elle se
construit avec les citoyens et que c'est
ce triangle qui fait que parce que la
santé ça touche directement directement
tous les sites web il ya d'autres sujets
qui touchent le citoyen mais là ça les
touche particulièrement et on voit bien
comment la sas est particulièrement
passé alors est-ce que ce triangle a été
parfaitement respectée moi je suis issu
du milieu vih on a construit sa avec
avec le milieu associatif et qui nous a
créé beaucoup bougé une fois de plus la
maladie n'appartient pas aux médecins
c'est la maladie d'un chacun et le
médecin est là pour accompagner un
patient ainsi c'est une vrai changement
radical de vision est ce qu on la
construit complètement un peu vite de ce
type
non je ne pense pas je pense que voilà
la construction d'un comité de citoyens
auraient été quelque chose d'important à
mes yeux c'est pas trop tard donc j'en
profite c'est pour ça que j'en profite
possible pour assister là dessus je les
dis publiquement aujourd'hui je pense
que la constitution d'un comité de
liaison citoyenne c'est pas un comité
théodule il peut se construire
je ne sais pas exactement comment
s'appuyant sur des choses déjà
existantes comme le lait le cns comme
bon il ya toute une série de choses qui
pourraient aider à reconstruire on
l'avait proposé comme tel permettrait
par être par exemple d'avoir une
réflexion sur il ya une deuxième vague
comment construites ont la réponse
citoyenne comment fait-on accepté entre
guillemets un certain nombre de
décisions difficiles comme anticipe-t-on
les problèmes générationnels qui risque
de se poser
quelles réflexions vraiment il ya sur la
table et ça serait probablement quelque
chose d'intéressant
donc voilà écoutez je termine juste
pour pour dire que d'abord je vous
remercie d'avoir passé autant de temps
avec nous premièrement je remercie une
fois de plus dans son élément du du
comité scientifique et finalement j'ai
j'ai quand même deux messages pour
terminer le premier c c'est anticiper
pour mieux préparer et le deuxième c'est
mais vous aurez l'occasion de le revoir
lors de vos deux de vos différentes
auditions
c'est je pense quand même qui en france
à avoir une vraie réflexion sur l'avenir
de la santé publique et la construction
de la santé publique merci monsieur je
me suis ciotti voulais rajouter quelque
chose et ont conclu la réunion monsieur
delfraissy vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question s'il vous plaît non m'excuser
de s'en charger une commission denquête
j'ai le droit de valence à mes questions
je vous isolez vous aurez les réponses à
vos caisses que je suis ne répond par
écrit c'est sûr je souhaitais que vous
est ce que vous imaginez réalisation des
tests db non je vous ai pas allez vous
me dites vous êtes au dessus
je veux juste savoir on va parler bon
sens je veux juste savoir monsieur
déprécie si vous avez et si vous avez
été consultés en même temps que le hcsp
sur sur l'analyse de cet article puisque
l'aca mener à des décisions dramatiques
et se sont forgés et simplement vous
répondrais oui ou non les ions je vais
vous rappeler ces règles non mais vous
allez répondre bien sûr je vous rappeler
juste une chose c'est que je préside
d'accord et personne n'a remis en
question jusque maintenant et c'est pas
parce que vous n'avez pas la réponse
satisfont me le dit on leur demande par
écrit on l'aura ces publics c'est dans
ces versets ça suffit
et nous ne sommes pas saisis sur les
données du lancet ce n'était pas notre
rôle
ce n'était pas notre rôle et nous sommes
mais nous ne sommes pas saisis
nous ne sommes pas saisis ni sur les
données violence est dans un premier
temps les données elles mêmes
on les a lus comme tout le monde je suis
un scientifique comme tout le monde
toute la table les à lui bien sûr
et deuxièmement sur ce qui s'est passé
sur l'interprétation de ces données du
l'ancêtre nous n'avons eu aucun rôle là
dedans c'est je vous le rappelle des
décisions prises par alors là des
agences comme le haut comité de santé
publique etc
voilà je ne peux pas être plus clair et
sur le test je pense que bruno lina vous
à vous a répondu ma vision sur
l'utilisation des tests je dirais de
début mars était une utilisation assez
large des tests dès qu'on pouvait les
avoir
je vous rappelle qu'on était une fois de
plus leur donnons les chiffres trois à
quatre mille tests que nous rentrons en
confinement et que donc la stratégie
elle était double de notre part un et
notre conseil il était doux premièrement
débrouillons nous pour fabriquer les
tests et avoir accès aux tests plus vite
possible et avec le bono s'est beaucoup
mouillé la chemise là dessus dans un
premier temps et pour arriver finalement
un point de sortie qu'on envisageait
plutôt fin avril ou début mai avec
plusieurs dizaines de milliers test par
jour ça c'était évidemment la première
priorité est la deuxième priorité si on
a des tests et entre temps chez qui les
utilisent et et nous avons changé les
dates exactes mais je pourrais vous les
données précises recommandé recommandé
que les tests soient particulièrement
utilisé au sein des ehpad
je crois qu'on avait déjà un bon
des réponses d'ailleurs nullement merci
madame la présidente juste en vous
remerciant mesdames et monsieur
messieurs monsieur le président
simplement vous avez évoqué à plusieurs
reprises vous même monsieur le président
est également le professeur qui l'a
bouadma des notes que vous avez adressé
des notes d' alerte qui je pense
s'insère dans un cadre différent que vos
avis public
je vous le demande devrait peut-être par
écrit mais si vous pouvez nous
communiquer les notes d' alerte vous
avez évoqué dans votre propos liminaire
des notes informel adressé aux au
pouvoir j'imagine ce sont pas des notes
public mais notre commission aimerait en
avoir connaissance
moi je vous remercie beaucoup furent
elles seront et après ce que j'ai voulu
évoquer par des informé par de
l'informel
c'était surtout du coup de téléphone
attention j'ai eu un coup de fil
justement de tel de telle région et
cetera qui me qui me fait dire que voilà
et vous pouvez le comprendre mais sur
les trois quatre notes non publique
d'achat vous venez d'entendre jean
françois delfraissy la justifier le
recours à un confinement total nous
n'avions pas le choix
le président du conseil scientifique a
déclaré que le risque d'une deuxième
vague à l'automne devait être considéré
cette audition et toutes celles de la
commission denquête sont à revivre tout
l'été sur lcp et à retrouver sur notre
site internet
lcp point fr